so joy reid i've talked about her a bit
over the last couple weeks now it's kind
of funny this is one of those things
which i've addressed before
when these people do these ridiculous
things on cnn and msnbc
nobody's really watching right like
msnbc's ratings
are terrible they're hugely funded by
giant corporate behemoths
they have massive staffs probably 20
upwards of 50 people on some of these
shows i have no idea exactly how many
they have at this point
but they have huge staffs they have huge
budgets
multiple producers directors everything
else as i always say to you guys i got
a i got a producer sitting right there i
got a director sitting right there i got
an intern
who's working from home and and then
what i say here it just it's whatever's
coming out of my mind i got a couple
notes and that's it but you get these
over produced shows
that are are basically democrat
propaganda that that's what joy reed is
she's a she's a democrat
propagandist by the way you can find
some very anti-gay writing of hers that
msnbc never addressed from about 20
years ago now of course if she was on
the right she would have been cancelled
and destroyed
but she's a lefty she's a democrat she's
a progressive so
so that's okay when you do that anyway
she's been going after chris ruffo and
most of you know chris ruffo i've had
him on the show a few times
he is a lawyer and what i love about
chris is he's a fighter
like this isn't a guy that's just
talking about stuff this is a guy who
has taken
the fight against critical race theory
against
race essentialism against the idea that
you are born
guilty because of your skin color in
this case white against the idea that we
should racialize
everything and that traits that once we
thought of as good things
like showing up on time and working hard
and knowing empirical facts like two
plus two equals four
that somehow these are white things and
these are things that must be destroyed
and that the founding of america
was evil because it was through white
people and all of these things and that
and that the
the real thing that brought america
together was slavery i mean these are
all nonsensical things
that are being pushed in all of our
schools they're they're one of the
reasons that everything seems to be
falling apart
we did a clip last week of barack obama
basically implying that that critical
race theory is not something to fight
against which tells you that it actually
is something to fight against the fact
that he even had to
go out there and say that because it
shows that the fight against
critical race theory is starting to work
right so texas florida several other
states have now passed
laws banning critical race theory being
taught in schools the same way you
wouldn't want nazism
say taught in schools you could teach
about the nazis but you wouldn't want to
teach
that the nazis with their racialist
ideas about the world
were the good guys right so chris is
doing an absolutely great job and he's
been calling out joy reid
and well she called him out on her show
this is a guy named christopher ruffo
who's at the conservative think tank
uh at a conservative think tank and he
says the goal is to have the public read
something crazy
in the newspaper and immediately think
critical race there we've decodified the
term
and will recodify it to annex the entire
range of cultural constructions that are
unpopular with americans
basically using critical race there is a
brand name oh absolutely it's a
distraction
it's a distraction uh okay i'm not even
sure who that other person was
but all right joy reid is sort of going
after the ideas that chris ruffo has put
out there there's many other moments
where she's been mentioning him
so chris did what you can do at least
for now
on a semi-free internet he tweeted at
joy read he said
joy reid has denounced me by name
multiple times on her show
but she doesn't have the courage to
invite me on as a guest she knows that i
will crush her
critical race theory apologetics any day
of the week so in essence he said hey
look i put some stuff
out there you don't like it you've
mentioned me by name
put me on your show let's talk about it
now i've been through many versions
of this myself right where mainstream
people go after me cnn or new york times
and i used to challenge everybody
debates and they they usually just
disappear
well then joy responded and really
listen to there's a particularly crazy
part of what she said here she wrote
this is a weirdly aggressive way to get
yourself on tv christopher
why not just contact my booking
producers like a normal person
rather than going with the white man
demands option
capitals on white man demands i had
never even heard of you until
underscore peace exposing your plot
to rebrand crt now okay it doesn't
matter when she heard of him she's
talking about him a lot now and making
him seem like he's some sort of
conservative bad guy because he's trying
to get race
obsession out of schools but there she
went ahead and did she already showed
her hand there first off what was the
line white what was it white what now
white man demands options so now she
racialized this conversation
she now looks at rufo and the and she
views him simply as a white man so
through the critical race lens right
through this lens where they racialize
everything well she did it there she
even put those words in capitals
so is a white man not allowed to ask to
be on a show
demands you're talking [ __ ] about him
and now he's asking
to talk to you so this is what they do
with everything by the way
i'm going to guess that it is possible
and i'll ask chris myself i'll actually
text him after this
i'll ask him if he went through the
proper channels whenever anyone anytime
i've called out somebody
online i always go through the proper
channels first and you always get
ignored so what would have happened i
would bet anything on this
is if chris went through the proper
channels he's just ignored
right and then he has to go public now
maybe he didn't but also
in the world of twitter and the way we
all communicate with each other if
someone calls you out
on their national cable news channel
show you're allowed to tweet at them and
say hey
you know can we talk he wasn't he wasn't
really being a dick about it
i don't think and then the end there
you're the until the piece
exposing your plot to rebrand critical
race theory
he's not trying to rebrand critical race
theory he's actually explained critical
race theory quite well
what he's trying to show people is that
when you hear these crazy things in the
media
that nobody fully understands and why
we're watching kids come home thinking
that their parents are racist
and the country is awful he wants them
to understand that that is directly
linked
to being taught the ideas of critical
race theory
but it's his plot i know it's his plot
it's very it's very very scary so
hopefully they will talk
i i sincerely doubt that they will um
not that
joy is going to go for it but i would
gladly offer them this channel
if they don't even want me in the way
i'll offer them this channel and my 1.7
million subscribers or whatever it is
to just get the message out there if
they just want to stream it right here
that would
uh be just fine with me but again this
is about
fighting back and you know i always tell
you the thing i don't like people who
just talk
and i think a couple years ago a lot of
my liberal friends were just talking
about talking
and just not really doing anything i
like people who build things
and i like people who fight and chris
ruffo is like the tip of the spear
of the fight on critical race theory and
it's just great and we'll see what
happens
with uh with miss joy reid but do google
joy read in her anti-gay writings and
then wonder why this woman is still
on msnbc